we have to stay on the main road
main road
aim detail
we go
[Music]
you don't have to do this
they aren't there anymore
suhanna go
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes you're dead
[Music]
[Music]
hi i'm mark harris i'm a film historian
and writer for new york magazine
and i'm here today talking to paul
greengrass
the co-writer and director of news of
the world paul
welcome how are you i'm good mark very
good to be here with you
um you know that scene that we just saw
there's the sense of course of great
tragedy
and violence having happened but the
scene itself
struck me as one of the gentlest scenes
and one of the quietest scenes that
you've
ever filmed so can you talk a little bit
about
your thinking behind that well i think
the
the the idea of my mind with this film
was that
all the actually all the the violence
had occurred well before the film
started all those kind of profound
experiences that both characters had
gone through in other words
the little girl and the kidnap and the
uh from her initial family and then
you know later the killing of her kiowa
family
that all occurred because before the
film starts
ditto kids experiences in the civil war
and what you know the the the story of
what's happened to his wife
that also has all occurred and i
wanted to make the film that way because
it through the focus
i hope or or throws the focus i hope
on the journey out of the bitter times
out of the division out of the
the pain if i can put it that way so
that the journey becomes
accounting for the past and
and you only understand the past through
watching
those characters confront it it's
wordless
you know and that's what that scene is
for the little girl she she's
going back to a a memory that for her
would has become vivid as the journey
has gone on
but it's all about stillness it's all
about just
her uh you know the wind
the light playing on her face through
that canvas
you know broken curtain and
that i think gives it a
a a sort of truthfulness in a way
and i think a tremendous burden rests on
her
as an actor i mean helena she she she
has to convey that story
uh just through her face
and she does it it's all in her eyes
yeah i was fascinated by
that because you know i thought of
captain phillips where
you had tom hanks uh an experienced
actor who
who certainly understands what the
camera can do and often
you had him paired on screen with uh a
much newer
uh actor and and again this time uh
you're you're not only working with with
a new actor but with a child what was
what was that like for you working
working with her you know i had
tremendous anxiety at the start of the
process i thought the big problem was
gonna be to find a
you know a young girl who can who could
go toe-to-toe with tom and
carry that part in the way that it needs
to be done
it it turned out to be the easiest
decision she she just done
system crasher which you probably know
it's a wonderful german film
and she was wonderful in that and then i
met her and we did some work together
for a day
i i have no doubts about her i mean you
know
there was a little anxiety going into
the first
day you know you go well how's this
going to work but
she was so strong from the first day
that i actually
never really thought of her as a child
of course she was a child and
and you know you were aware of it you
know uh
off off camera as it were but when she
was performing she had just
such great confidence there was a a
moment in this particular scene i
i remember we did a take and i adjusted
james that operator's movement uh
so that she went the other way around
and we rotated in the opposite direction
and i was explaining this to james and
tadarus what i wanted and she was
standing off to one side she said
oh yes she said i understand so i will
wait until
the cameras move around this is when i
will make sure that i display the
emotion
she said oh
yeah that's that's right i mean she had
a
tremendous confidence in her acting
ability and rightly so i think
well one thing i really love about what
you did with that scene is that it's
such a delicate act of physical
choreography because of course we're
very much
with her as she walks into that empty
space but you
also really want to give us the space
itself and and and the room to
imagine uh the the terrible things that
happened there and
and for us also to understand that she's
imagining it so
and as you said it's all really silent
so
you know it must have been a really
interesting challenge to know
how how much time you could give
yourself to let that play out in a
realistic way
look you know the truth about directing
is
you you you you're given tremendous
credit
for credit that belongs to your team in
truth
and and this is an example of that you
know
this the the cinematography is
magnificent you know the the what darius
captures it the light the play of the
light
the naturalness of it you know the the
the depth of the shadow just enough not
too much
uh the operating superlative
you know so sensitive um the design
david cranks design you know that's just
it you believe it it's dressed so
beautifully and so simply and you
believe
that it's that place the music shows new
exquisite and just the way the music
doesn't lead you that's so important
you know such an important element to
the scene
and yet you feel she moves and draws the
music
it's not the music pushing her and uh
and we the audience it's it's her
emotion that
that draws the music in and it's so
exquisitely
subtle i think and yet so so beautiful
so
you know i mean i can talk about the
makeup it's exquisite because her face
looks
what it would be whether beaten lived
you know but not excessively so just
subtlety everywhere so i think all these
things have to come together when you
make films
and you know as the director
there's a you know saying you just have
to get out the way of people very often
when it's gonna happen
when it's right when people have done
the work the
costume is so perfect isn't it it sits
that you know the shade of that dress is
not too intense it sits in the
in the palette of that landscape
perfectly it's a child's dress
and yet it's not too childish you know i
mean that those choices are so
subtle and get any of them wrong in any
of those areas
and the scene is not what it is and uh
yeah i was very very lucky on this film
to have
all that really creative
excellence you know every day people
brought it to work
and and people loved making that
movie loved being in that landscape
loved its
echoes of the searches you know well i
wanted to talk about that because i know
that you're
uh an old movie aficionado like i
am and you know one word that i've heard
uh people who love this movie use over
and over again
to describe it is classical it's it's
not a throwback it is it is a very
modern movie in its way but but it it
the the the blood of previous movies
runs through it in a really
moving to me way and i i wonder if you
could talk a little bit about
what what was what was spooling through
your mind as as you worked on this
well i mean five came back to be honest
you know because john ford
you know your wonderful book and that
that project and that of course that
that made me re-watch all ford's movies
again and obviously i
watched them many times but i hadn't
watched them
in a block like that it was a couple of
years later that i
read the novel news of the world but as
soon as i read the novel
i thought with the searches you know
it's it's really the search is in
reverse
isn't it you know in the searches wayne
goes out to find
the girl in the desert in this hanks
finds the girl at the front of the film
and the journey is the is the attempt to
try and bring her
home or to what he thinks is her home
and
and i thought that was really
interesting because it it provided
the sort of classical western uh
narrative you know very common isn't it
that that and yet it enabled
the film to traverse a more modern
landscape or
or a landscape that was both classically
western but also resonant of today
perhaps put it like that would be better
and i loved that and and i wanted
i suppose to to
[Music]
to to reference the searches most
explicitly in this scene and obviously
particularly that
that shot when you look out through the
shack at the two of them
together um and
and i love that because
the truth is when you make a western
you're you're clambering imperfectly
up the shoulders of a of many giants but
particularly football
you know and and there was a time
i can't remember what scene we were
shooting we were out in the desert
it was late one afternoon the light was
beautiful and i was
sitting down as they prepared the shot
with james newton how who did the score
with billy goldenberger cut the film so
beautifully
gary gets one and greg goodman were
there the producers and we were chatting
i think there was something about the
light
and the landscape and the wagons and the
horses you kind of felt that you were
you could feel papa ford out there
children
calling to you and we actually started
giggling you know like like school
kids because there was something
wonderful about working in this
mythic genre that's so much part
of of you know it's one of the
central pillars of american narrative
cinema isn't it and
and it's the idea that we were trying in
our small way
to breathe a bit you know some new life
into it was
was was both
boyish you know
it liberated the inner child in you
but also inspired us i think you know
and and that's why i think there was
such tremendous work by
all those wonderful people because to
work in that genre is to
feel yourself close to the masters of
the past
you know what i mean in a way that that
that in a more contemporary landscape is
harder to feel
if i put it that way right although one
thing i really love about it is that
you know we so often tend to divide
westerns into traditional westerns and
revisionist westerns and
and i don't think you can easily place
uh
news of the world in in one category or
another because it does have
these traditional values and yet it
isn't a movie that would have been made
in the 1940s or 1950s
i think look i
when you make a movie it's you've got to
be true to what's in your heart
you know uh i grew up with westerns
as a boy you know they were always on
television of course in the uk
um
but also
i experience living in troubled times as
you do in your country you know
i think we are in very very difficult
divided bitter times and
and so to make a film that
the purpose of which was to was
predicated on the idea that there are
better dates to come but we will find
our way out
this that's really what brought me to it
i wanted to make a film
for my kids about what that road might
feel like i didn't know it was going to
be
news the world i didn't know it was
going to be a western but now i look
back on it
you know after it's finished i see that
there's something
both comforting and inspiring
to go to core genres
and and feel the power of them
feel the truth of them feel them animate
you
towards better days and when that scene
finishes that scene we're talking about
and
she comes outside and she comes
hesitantly towards
kid and she takes his hand
and you know she asks him if her parents
are dead and they are and he says they
are
and she takes his hand it's the first
time
they've touched it's and they move off
and it feels so affecting to me the
acting there from both of them
because it's a recognition
it's not sentimental it's not it
it gives appropriate weight to the
pain and the grief and the difficulties
of the past
and yet it's a step towards reconnection
and the rest of the film really starts
to develop that idea
and so that was what was in my heart
that's what i
that and the and the the genres
sustained me in that feeling if i can
put it that way
paul greengrass thank you so much news
of the world a beautiful movie thanks
for spending time with us
thanks mom
you